[Applaudissements]
bonjour il y à 40 ans de cela je suis né
le 19 novembre 2016
j'assistais à la conférence ted x de la
rochelle suite à cette conférence
je suis rentré chez moi à bouleverser
qu'est-ce que j'ai foutu mais clé
or les eaux qu'aristide qui déconne
attends tu étais rentré dans ta voiture
tu es un à déconnecter ton cerveau tu as
roulé tu as fait le tour du porte est
rentré dans les poches intérieures
d'habitude mais télécommande mais là
j'ai dû me gilles ouimet de mes clés
paul combien de fois je t'ai dit de ne
pas sauter sur le canapé paul tu
descends jules tu peux continuer c'est
super chérie chéri je suis bouleversé le
shérif ou est ce qu'elle est je commence
à douter que les choses soient claires
tu m'as laissé un message mais si j'ai
pas répondu c'est parce que j'étais
occupé il est hyper important que tu
doutes tout et intuition tu les écoutes
beaucoup trop chéri c'était pareil
pourtant l'hétérosexualité heureusement
que j'ai mis le paquet on a des troupes
dans le jardin je te raconte pas la
galère corps écoute ces problèmes là
pourront passer après la révélation j'ai
eu ce soir j'étais au tmx de la rochelle
tu parles de tes conneries là tu passes
ton temps en réunion c'est pas une
réunion ce sont des conférence
inspirante
les gens y passent la journée dans l'eau
alors qu'il fait beau dehors et qui
pourrait se promener ils pensent qu'ils
vont changer le monde en restant le cul
sur une chaise à écouter une réunion
comme celle des gens qui raconte des
trucs pendant quinze et vingt huit on
peut me figure toi et moi ça m'a donné
envie de faire de grandes choses hein
quoi par exemple
comme quoi je sais pas il se trouve que
depuis que je suis née et j'ai rien fait
j'ai rien réalisé cette fois l abri de
jardin et superbe au fond du jardin
c'est même pas moi qui les fais on a
demandé un artisan parce que je sais pas
planter des clous mais on peut pas
changer le monde écoute nicolas hulot
est venu à la maison hier soir il nous
l'a dit et c'est pas la peine de vous
emballer comme ça vous changez rien mais
peut-être que nicolas hulot il a tort en
tout cas moi ça m'a donné envie de
réaliser de grandes choses voilà es-tu
m'empêchera pas de le faire mais j'en ai
pas l'intention si c'est ce que tu veux
faire et barre suite à route
je vais commencer tout de suite je vais
me lancer un défi physique
enfin mon chéri tu n'as jamais pu porter
une pièce de plus de 3 kg atteint faut
que tu as voulu partir en randonnée la
plus grande course que tu avais fait
c'était 30 mètres pour un ajustement
l'abri dire la wii bien mais là je me
suis senti pousser des ailes jouer en
puis tant pis je marche jusqu'au port je
serai le premier homme à nager de la
rochelle à new york
voilà revient pas trop tard parce que la
boue sera froide à un petit garçon
un jour pris sa trottinette pour monter
jusqu'en haut de l'himalaya je te vois
partir comme ça jusqu'au bord et je me
dis il te manque sûrement quelque chose
est-ce que tu as pensé à désherber ton
cerveau non je pensais faire ça après
est ce que tu es prêt à faire ce voyage
quand tu rentreras de ce voyage tu seras
capable de te laver avec un demi-verre
d'eau tu ne partiras plus jamais en
pique nique tu partiras et hop tu
t'inviterai auprès des gens qui sont en
train de manger même s'ils ont rien
demandé
est ce que tu es prêt à revenir comme ça
oui
si au fond de ton coeur tu n'es pas prêt
alors n'y va pas mais si tu es prêt au
fond de ton coeur 37 asperges
je vais poser une question essentielle
oui tu ne me répondra que quand tu seras
revenu par qu'elle vous souhaites tu la
manges et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis détendu plus détendu cours béton
et chine bourse or jeune âge port de
tête droit et jeune âge tu as envie de
vomir ces normes actuelles mal de mer
avale tous vos mii à brac jeu de tête
est très ralentie
sordo non tu marches sur le sable tu es
beau pense à paul tu es prêt je suis
déjà à new york
oui il fallait faire et voir houston
délit lagos et shanghaï mais new york ça
marche
bienvenue merci bon voyage excusez moi
vous n'avez pas enlever votre bonnet
c'était bien lui excusez moi monsieur
jean pierre je te bloque 12
le bloc 12 à je ne sais pas ici je vous
êtes sur la 42e à l'angle avec queen
street
ca c c'est complètement fasciné à chaque
fois que je pose cette question au genre
de savoir où se trouve le bloc 12 oui
76,31 % des gens ont la réponse
le reste ne l'a pas et 0 8 % ne savent
même pas lire une carte vous venez d'où
ça serait trop compliqué de vous
répondre dans le plus confiance à mes
intuitions depuis le début
je suis prof de maths vous êtes prof de
maths
tout à fait ça tombe bien parce que
quand j'étais jeune mes élèves maps et
l'oma 3 cos et puisque j'ai toujours un
mouchoir au milieu c'est cadeau mais
pour voir sont sans limites
moi je vous êtes plusieurs à l'intérieur
dont je vous raconterai vous aime
beaucoup vos chaussures salies comme
enjeu je vois là je cherche à akoupé ce
fils qui me relie à ma culture pour
mieux vous comprendre prend ceux des
lances le tu vois ici c'est une carte de
la vie tu l'a lancé action-réaction ses
retombées t'as vu ouais tu apprends et
c'est pas toujours comme ça dans la vie
tu peux lancer tu avanceras champions
mais attention je suis en case 54 autant
dire que si tu fais 4 au nom la case
avec la tête de mort je reviens au début
il exactement
mais là on peut en sortir la ville lance
je lance d'abord où j'attends que vous
me donniez un conseil lancé 1,6
bienvenue en 15 60
t'avais dit que les mathématiques était
la réponse
waouh vous êtes mathématicien je suis
plus que ça
je suis pythagore vous êtes le vrai
pythagore ou alors celui qui choppe tous
les soirs depuis plus de 600 ans et oui
mon bonhomme pas ce qu'on tape montré
des pierres précieuses des trucs comme
ça mais la vérité ce sont les
mathématiques pour la suite de ton
parcours
tu vas tout compte et 960 par neuf cent
soixante neuf cent soixante neuf cent
soixante neuf cent soixante mille neuf
cent soixante neuf jusqu'au bout tout
droit tu croiseras sur ta route des gens
qui auront besoin d aide
oui c'est ça ta very des aides laitue
t'aidera toi même et oui depuis le début
je cherche à réaliser des grandes choses
mais non parfois il suffit de commencer
par son monde fait appel à théo
terroriste et que tu sais conduire
d'amiens
[Musique]
c'est la première personne il s'arrête
et depuis deux jours on est arrivés en
intéresser personne ou le gall personnes
nous paraît encore planer ainsi qu'ils
disent et les gens ils sont vraiment pas
gentil bonjour oui pardon excusez moi je
suis désolé je saurai vous prévenir
nous sommes nous sommes nous sommes à
nouveau en france on se fait la bise
mais ça doit vous paraître un peu
bizarre moi même j'ai fait un voyage et
je me suis coupé de ma culture alors je
compte que ce soit compliqué pour vous
rien compris à ce qu'il a dit en fait
c'est quand vous voulez vous demander
ses caisses que si vous pouviez aller à
l'étape d'après si on pouvait aller à
l'étape d'après c'est sa montée dans la
voiture c'est très sympa en principe
c'est pas dangereux en moyenne les gens
ils vont d'un point a à un point b en
moyenne on arrive à peu près à
destination mais on ne s'est pas
présenté connaissait pas le nom
wicked vous allez zik des pleins alors
je suis damien au moi aussi je m'appelle
damien c'est vrai je m'appelle daniel
ambert
moi aussi c'était une soeur qui
s'appelle marion lambert
oui j'ai une soeur qui s'appelle mario
lambert a scellé moment où ils m'avaient
de la voiture votre père c'est pas
bernard lambert et si vos verres vous
habitez dans le xiii débloque la 14e
maison à tokyo mais oui alors c'est
qu'on sait qu'on est frais
mais oui maintenant je me rappelle et
oui moi aussi mais qu'est ce que tu fais
là
vous savez pas reconnu tu t'es laissé
pousser la barbe je suis parti depuis si
longtemps que ça j'ai fait des
recherches
je fais de recherche depuis tout ce
temps je pense avoir la réponse
répond à mes questions oui de quelle
couleur est le carton pour exclure un
joueur blanc de quelle couleur et le
john tu peux prendre une séance de ted
rouge
de quelle couleur et le parti communiste
qu'est-ce que boit un vampire du sang
non ça marche pas je cherche encore je
ne trouve pas alors je suis désolé je
vais être je vais chercher encore oui
rentre à la maison je vais être embêtant
là ça fait 17 minutes que vous êtes garé
au même endroit on a des protocoles très
précis la procédure c'est 12 de la
mairie atari de rester là plus de 15
minutes
alors si je vous aime beaucoup ça va pas
être possible de rester plus longtemps
je suis désolé on essaie de discuter de
merde ça marchait pas on l'a tous fait
défaut vous partir mais je dors le
service public le tout mon coeur et ça
ne change rien à ma vie et le formulaire
des 212
non j'ai pas le formulaire mais 212 très
bas formulaire 212 alors vous me suivez
non en prison tout c'est une norme fait
pas jouer vous ici s'il vous plaît mais
enfin c'est comme ça qu'on traite les
gens maintenant exactement chez voo foot
en cellule avec les pires terroristes de
la terre c'est simple ils s'appellent
tous paul
d'exemple en insupportable qu'on a élevé
comme des merdes les ravages de 80%
d'éducation stressante et négatives
quand j'étais petit ma main est même été
tout le temps en quoi la [ __ ]
lol tu vas morfler mon bonne âme parce
que je te préviens dans cette cellule
c'est vraiment la merde un petit garçon
une fois a réussi à s'échapper d'une
cellule en mangeant les barreaux avec
les dents il a réussi à faire évacuer
toute sa famille toute étude
je suis bien dans la cellule le farsi
c'est bien ici c'est là c'est la pire
prison du monde
oui j'adore ça
attendez excusez nous mais plus ça pue
plus c'est la meilleure puce la cride à
j'adore génial il ya vraiment des reins
et tout ben ouais en fait on a qu'on a
que ça à manger ouais je crois que c'est
le plus beau jour de ma vie excusez moi
on a mis des canards pour bouffer les
rapaces que ça fertiliser le sol
on va travailler en mode projet on va
sortir de cette cellule
d'accord ça sera un peu triste parce que
sans ça - la merde mais mais tant pis
faut bien passer par là non mais il ya
vraiment des choses formidables
je veux dire il ya des gens qui se bouge
partout où il ya des des petits projets
qui naissent ici ou là il ya des
enseignants qui font des choses
formidables je suis moi même père de
deux enfants qui vont dans une école et
je me dis tout le temps est ce que je
les laisse à l'école et est ce que je
les envoie faire un tour du monde
oui pons laver avec une bouteille d'eau
est ce que m pap a bousillé de faire
quoi là vous cherchez à me rendre b1
vous croyez que j'ai envie à 90 ans de
me faire chier encore écrire des
bouquins avec moi préfèrent partir parce
que c'est la mère d'ailleurs attendait
non vous allez trouver une sortie tu as
presque fini c'est l'ultime épreuve
ah oui c'est vrai l'épreuve de la femme
qui tourne
ne fais plus ne fait pas confiance à ton
cerveau d'amérique te raconte des
conneries je sais je vais rendre cet
ordinateur intelligent afin qu'ils
résolvent le problème trop complexe pour
mon cerveau d'êtres humains en effet
bravo je tournais dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre
mais là n'était pas la question je
voulais des chaussures
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ma conférence ted
j'espère que vous aussi à votre niveau
lequel mort choisissent une cible
commencer petit pas par petit pas vous
avez le pouvoir de changer le monde
ça commence par aller prendre un
cocktail à la sortie de saw ted je sais
que vous n'êtes pas vraiment là puisque
nous sommes en 2056
si ce que j'ai dit au début de cette
restitution est vrai et que vous n'êtes
pas là puisque vous avez tous été
remplacés par des ordinateurs et que
vous êtes à la plage donc alors à tous
ceux qui depuis leur smartphone greffer
à leur main me regarde
regardez vous sentez votre palpitant 200
vélos vibrer boom pow pow est maintenant
levé vous chers jamais ou et car c'est
la fin alors levé vous mettez vous
debout
envoyez la musique c'est la valse tango
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
aïe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]